i just had surgery for a condition
called endometriosis
and after the surgery the doctor told me
that given how advanced it was i've
probably had it for 15 years
what's crazy though is that this is such
a common disease and i've gone and seen
so many doctors
and yet i only just got diagnosed with
it this year
[Music]
the clip that you just saw was from two
months ago and i'm very well now so
don't worry about me i also want to say
that this video is going to say some
things that i think should change about
medicine but this isn't a complaint
about the medical attention i've
received because i'm very very grateful
i mean look at these photos from my
surgery endometriosis at least in the
later stages can glue a bunch of your
organs together which is why some of
these photos are such a mess but
i mean
look at the photo from afterwards
that's an extreme makeover it took a
long time to get this diagnosis though
i'd been to many doctors and asked about
my mystery illness sometimes i'd
complain about period pain or about the
bloating or about how i'd often feel so
tired it felt like i was moving through
a haze they'd always try and help me but
nothing really worked and i thought that
maybe these symptoms were just normal
and it was all manageable anyway so i
just kind of didn't do anything
eventually though the pain became pretty
extreme and it wouldn't stop so i called
the gp
he said he had no idea what was wrong
but agreed that this wasn't normal and
he sent me off to get an ultrasound
meanwhile though i idiotically decided
to google my symptoms and decided that
the sudden pain was probably from an
ovarian cyst ovarian cysts can cause
intense pain like i was having but
they're benign and they go away on their
own and so i just decided that i
probably didn't need to go back to the
doctor to see the ultrasound results i
let a month go by but then i came across
this ai medical diagnosis app called ada
it asks you some questions about your
symptoms and then tells you the
probability that you might have some
disease it told me that i likely had
endometriosis a condition i'd never
heard of it sounded serious enough so i
went to the doctor and lo and behold
that's what my ultrasound showed that i
had how is it that an app was able to
figure out what i had with a few simple
questions that's what this video is
about i'm going to explain why the
problem of diagnosing something is a
very challenging mathematical problem
involving something called a causal
bayesian network we'll see why humans
have a hard time with this sort of
problem and how computer algorithms can
help
suppose someone like me wants to find
out if they have endometriosis
first we need to know how common is this
condition
pretty common unfortunately
approximately 1 in 10 people who are
assigned female have it
it's going to be useful to think about
that probability by imagining 10
different people just like me who are
getting diagnosed
one of these people is the unlucky one
who has endo and the other nine don't
but none of them know their fate yet
now let's ask them about their symptoms
very painful periods are a hallmark of
endo pretty much everyone with this
condition has it and so this person will
too
however some of these people without
endo will also have it
how many i found it really hard to get a
good estimate that i trusted so instead
of giving an accurate number here i'm
going to overestimate it just for the
sake of argument i'll say that one-third
of people without endo have comparably
painful periods
if this were all true and one of these
10 people said that they don't have
painful periods then what can you deduce
if a person doesn't have the symptom
then according to this picture they must
be one of these six and so you can be
sure that they don't have endo
if someone instead says that they do
have this symptom then they must be one
of these four people
so what's the chance that they have endo
now
the chance is one out of four
so by knowing this one symptom we were
able to increase a person's chance of
having endo from one in ten to one in
four
remember this is probably an
underestimate because i overestimated
how common bad period pain is for
healthy people
we can get more information though to
really narrow down the chances by asking
these people about another symptom
bloating
some sort of bloating or digestive pain
is a very common symptom of endo i saw
one study that claimed it was around 80
vendor sufferers who had it for the sake
of this calculation though i'll pretty
much assume that it's a hundred percent
even though that's not true just because
it's a little bit easier
you can verify that this doesn't change
the numbers too much
how about the people without endo
again it was really hard to find
information so i'm gonna overestimate
i'll say that about a third of these
people have it
now if someone tells you that they have
both heavy periods and bloating what's
the probability that they have endo
well they can't be one of these two
since they don't have both of those
symptoms
they must be either this person with
endo or this person without so the
probability that they have endometriosis
is a half
in our model having both bad period pain
and bloating makes the chance that you
have endo around 50
the numbers i use for this little
calculation certainly aren't accurate
but i hope that they showed you how you
can turn pieces of evidence that on
their own aren't that conclusive like
symptoms or even blood tests and
ultrasound tests and combine them to get
a more solid picture
this is called bayes rule in particular
this is bayes rule in the ratio form
which in my opinion is way more useful
than the usual way it's written down
however bayes theorem isn't going to cut
it for the actual problem of diagnosis
that's because in the real world there
are so many potential conditions that a
person could have
this calls for causal bayesian networks
let's see what those are by imagining a
simple world where there are only two
conditions a and b
it's possible for you to have one of
these none or even both
each of these has a bunch of symptoms
that it can cause however they'll also
have some symptoms in common
let's say that tiredness is a symptom of
both but it's a more common symptom of a
than b
what that means is if you have both a
and b you'll definitely be tired whereas
if you have neither then you won't be
tired for sure
but if you only have a then your
probability of being tired is a half
whereas if you only have b you have a
one quarter probability of being tired
suppose that someone in this world is
tired should you diagnose them with a or
b
or both
you might have said a since the symptom
is more likely for a but that's not the
only thing to think about
what if a is less common than b
say its probability is a quarter and b's
is a half
given this new information
how should you diagnose the patient
the calculation i'm about to show you
isn't obvious in fact when i was
drafting this video i realized i'd
forgotten how to do it i had to sit for
a while and reinvent the wheel
the trick is the fruitful way to think
about all this is by considering the
four disjoint possibilities
a patient might have both a and b only a
only b or neither a nor b
what's the probability for each of these
let's work it out
the probability of having a and b is the
probability of a times the probability
of b
the probability of just having a is the
probability of a times the probability
of not having b that's a tricky one
we can work out the other two in a
similar vein i've written these
probabilities as a ratio because all i
really care about is how likely each of
these is compared to the others
another way to think of it is this for
every eight people in this world one
will have a and b
one will have just a three will have
just b and three will have neither how
many people will tell you that they're
tired for this we're going to need to
consult our punnett square the
probability that a person in the a and b
category has tiredness is one so
everyone in the group has it on the
other hand only half the people who have
just a are tired
one quarter of the people with just b
are tired and none of the people without
the diseases are tired
we want this ratio to look nice again so
we're just going to multiply everything
by 4 but that doesn't actually affect
anything
so what does this say
it says if we only look at people who
are tired for every 4 of them that have
both a and b
two have just a
and three have just b
in the end then if someone tells you
that they're tired you can conclude that
they're a little bit more likely to have
b than a overall but the most likely
thing is that they have both when i
wrote this example i tried to rig the
numbers so that both a and b would end
up equally likely so i was really
surprised to see that it didn't work out
that way
last night i spent ages trying to get
some intuition for y and try to figure
out how you could easily tell which
disease was going to be the more common
one without having to do all this
calculating
i couldn't figure it out though so guess
what that's homework
no really i'd like you to figure this
out for me okay so back to the bayesian
network and our patient who's just told
us that they're tired
for this symptom we can say that both a
and b are almost equally likely but
let's try and narrow it down
which of these symptoms would you ask
about next
let's ask about something that's a
common symptom of a but isn't super
common amongst people without a and
isn't caused by b
if a person says that they have that
symptom then that would raise the
probability of a
if you've done some econometrics before
then you might recognize this as an
instrumental variable
here's a tough question though because
this patient was tired we found the
probability of them having b to b seven
over nine
now that we know that they also have
this symptom of a and the probability of
a has gone up as a result does that
change the probability of b again
feel free to pause the video and really
think about this because it's a tough
question
the answer is
it does
the reason the probability of b was high
in the first place was because tiredness
needed an explanation and a and b are
both possible explanations
but now that we have more reason to
believe that a happened we don't need b
as an explanation as much therefore the
probability of it becomes lower
that was a tricky situation so to
understand it i recommend that you make
up some numbers for this intuition and
verify it mathematically
i did this when i was making this video
and it really helped me clarify what it
means for something to be a symptom of a
but not b so honestly try it anyway you
can see that these bayesian networks can
be hard to understand even in the case
where there's just two diseases that are
independent from each other but what
about the case when they're both related
by some other disease or when there's
many symptoms for each
every time you find out a patient does
or doesn't have a symptom you need to
update all of the probabilities involved
as you can see it's very hard for a
human to keep such a vast network in
their brain and correctly update all
these probabilities as new information
comes in whereas computers have a much
easier time of this that doesn't mean
that i think the computer should
completely take over diagnosing patients
though there's lots of advantages the
human doctor has for example doctors
understand patients better and are
better equipped to translate what the
patient is saying into actual accurate
symptoms
that's why i think that a hybrid
approach is probably best maybe before
coming in a patient should answer
questions from the ai and then the
computer can synthesize what it thinks
is the most likely issue and the doctor
can use that information to help them
when they're talking to the patient
but what do you think i'm not a real
doctor so there's probably all kinds of
subtleties that i'm missing here so for
your first bit of homework i'd love to
hear what you think about this problem
the second thing i'd like you to do is
if you have some of the symptoms that i
did or a friend of yours does please
read the extra information that i've put
in the description and seek medical help
and ask about endometriosis specifically
and here's the fun homework i want you
to dig into the mathematics of this
stuff starting with the two problems
i've mentioned already
try it and send me your working out
either here on twitter i'll post a
follow-up in a week based on what you
guys send in
okay good luck have fun
you